100 Euro sind 2000 türkische Lira 14.000
japanische Yen oder 1,6 Millionen
indonesische rupia das Geld ist überall
auf der Welt unterschiedlich viel wert
aber wie weit kommen wir real als
Touristen mit 100 € in Indien oder
Thailand Japan oder Brasilien der Türkei
oder Mexiko finden wir es gemeinsam
heraus viel Spaß mit 100 € in Panama
City
[Musik]
natürlich müssen wir auch in Panama City
gestärkt in den Tag gehen an dem wir
probieren mit 100 € möglichst viel zu
machen glücklicherweise sind wir in
einem Hotel in einem Hostel über das ich
euch später noch mal mehr erzähle in dem
super viel abgedeckt wird und auch ein
sehr gutes Frühstück zu einem
vernünftigen Preis bekommen kann ich
schon mal sagen eine Nacht inklusive
Frühstück wenn man sich zu zweit kostet
so ungefähr 31 Euro aber warte mal kurz
um im Ausland irgendwas bezahlen zu
können müssen wir erstmal Geld tauschen
sollte man meinen die paramesische
Landeswährung bei boah ist aber nur in
München im Umlauf und eins zu eins an
den US-Dollar gekoppelt weswegen hier
alles in US Dollar gezeigt wird und weil
ein Dollar zur Zeit unserer Reise genau
1 € wert war mussten wir hier nicht mal
umrechnen im Kreis in Begriffen ist im
Prinzip ein frühstücksgericht und ein
Getränk mich jetzt Cappuccino und
Avocado Toast und für den Preis absolut
top also ich glaube günstiger kommen wir
in so einem fancy Restaurant hier in der
Stadt woanders auch nicht weg aber es
gibt natürlich günstigeres essen da
werden wir uns dann heute Mittag oder
Nachmittag noch mal
so wie ich Panama kennengelernt habe ist
eine Stadt der Kontraste also nicht nur
ist es hier drin jetzt ziemlich leise
und draußen super laut und hier ist
super viel los und die Stadt lebt die
ganze Zeit sondern die Stadt ist vor
allem auch extrem alt extrem neu extrem
reich und extrem arm und das alte und
neue schauen wir uns jetzt als erstes an
Panama City ist die Hauptstadt und
größte Stadt Panamas neben seiner ultra
modernen Skyline voller Banken die sich
auch viele westliche Geschäftsmänner zu
Nutze gemacht haben Stichwort Panama
papers gab es hier insbesondere im
letzten Jahr immer wieder heftige
Proteste wegen sozialer Ungleichheit
vielleicht sieht es hier gerade schon
das Hotel ist in einer ziemlich coolen
Lage also wir sind würde ich sagen so
für die Kölner im Belgischen Viertel von
Panama City alte Gebäude quasi die
coolen Altbauten mit hohen Decken aber
alles auf neu gemacht neue Bars neue
Restaurants super viel junges Leben der
Kontrast ist aber ziemlich krass weil
die Grenze zu den Slums und dem ganzen
Kram ist super eng das beste aber
natürlich andere Städten die historisch
so viel zu bieten haben ist dass man das
alles kostenlos erleben kann also viele
der Infos gibt's online ist relativ
günstig irgendwelche Stadt Erfahrungen
zu machen davon werden wir heute absehen
denn das ist überhaupt nicht mein
dingslauf lieber selber so ein bisschen
rum und das ist wie in New York auch
schon komplett kostenlos sich einen
richtig geilen Eindruck von der Stadt
holen also 0 € für einen guten Eindruck
der Stadt und damit ihr checkt wo Panama
City überhaupt ist ziemlich genau hier
südlich davon haben wir auf einer
kleinen Insel seven the strike gedreht
und nördlich gibt es noch eine Menge
weitere Inseln auf dem wir ein 200 €
Karibik Hotel getestet haben dass ihr
nächste Woche sehen werdet
[Musik]
die Taxis Hupen einen hier übrigens die
ganze Zeit an weil die einen mitnehmen
wollen also sie wird wie in vielen der
anderen Mittel südamerikanischen
südostasiatischen Ländern ziemlich viel
gehupt
aber wie sieht's eigentlich aus hier mit
Transport ihr erinnert euch in New York
waren wir nur mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs
das wäre zwar in unserem Hostel auch
möglich gewesen ich wollte diesmal aber
ein bisschen Abwechslung reinbringen und
vor allem ist es ja ein Panama City
unheimlich günstig mit uber oder Taxi zu
fahren mit dem Taxi wahrscheinlich etwas
teurer weil wir Europäer sind und die
Taxifahrer am Preisen nehmen was auch
immer Sie wollen mit uber ist wirklich
unvergleichlich günstig 15 Minuten Fahrt
ungefähr drei Dollar und das die ganze
Zeit das wundert mich auch ein bisschen
weil ihr werdet gleich noch sehen an
anderen Stellen bezahlt man fast
europäischen Preise
hallo von David also tatsächlich
ziemlich cool mit dem oberrum zu fahren
man fährt durch super viele verschiedene
Stadtteile kann super viel sehen fährt
überall dran vorbei und entdeckt
vielleicht sogar noch Sachen die man
sonst an dem Tag noch machen will wir
haben gerade super viel von draußen
fotografiert mit dem iPhone einfach ein
Bild machen damit die Location ja
gespeichert und wir wissen dann später
wo wir hin wollen
[Musik]
über 20 Minuten Fahrt und nur knapp 5 $
also es ist wirklich unglaublich in der
Panamakanal angekommen und werden uns
jetzt mal etwas mit der Geschichte des
Panamakanals auseinandersetzen der im
übrigen dafür verantwortlich ist
größtenteils warum Panama so unendlich
reich ist und sie sind tatsächlich
wirklich sehr reich aber was ist der
Panama Kanal eigentlich im Prinzip haben
die Amis 1904 angefangen einfach durch
Panama hindurch zu buddeln und mit
Schiffen nicht mehr komplett um
Südamerika herumfahren zu müssen um z.B
nach Europa zu kommen deswegen
profitieren wir auch krass davon
bis 1999 alle Gebühren für Durchfahrt
etc eingesagt mittlerweile gehört der
Kanal wieder zu 100% Panama und ist ein
Riesengeschäft mit über 13.000
Durchfahrten in 20 21 und auf diese
Aussichtsplattform kann man den Schiffen
eben beim Prozess in der Schleuse zu
gucken so wie es hinter mir aussieht
sieht seit 10 Minuten aus die wir hier
sind mega nervig komplett alles ist voll
der direkte Sicht aufs Boot muss man
wahrscheinlich durch 30 Minuten warten
sich ergattern ist Ticket hat aber 10 €
gekostet das Museum auf dem Weg hier
hoch zu Plattform absolute Enttäuschung
ich würde fast sagen dass das hier die
schlechtesten zehn Euro waren die ich
bisher im Panama ausgegeben habe also
klar wir werden jetzt warten bis wir
vorne dran kommen aber es ist echt
nervig wirklich wirklich nervig
[Musik]
ja einfach so 15 Dollar Greenscreen
Fotos ich erschießt mich Fazit meiner
Meinung nach verbrannte 10 €, das war
genauso beeindruckend auf Youtube viel
viele Leute übelst stressig ganz klar
keine Empfehlungen zu fahren wenn ihr
ein Panama City seid bleibt einfach in
der Stadt macht irgendwas cooles mit den
10 € kann man deutlich coolere Sachen
anfangen genug Duri Aktivitäten rein ins
Abend teuer hier am Straßenrand gesehen
ich wollte das schon immer mal machen
und deswegen checken jetzt mal ab wie
viel neue Haarschnitt kostet wir sind
mitten in Panama City so sieht's aus
aber geil und jetzt checken
liebe Grüße an meinen Friseur vatik du
musst das vielleicht wieder fixen wenn
es nichts wird
[Musik]
das Ding ist ich weiß natürlich dass ich
abgezogen werde der Preis den ich
bezahle ist natürlich Touri Preis aber
es ist wunderbar macht trotzdem eine
Menge Laune und ich wollte es eh schon
immer mal machen also super und ich
meine ist halt immer noch Hammer günstig
einfach normale Küchenschere kein
Problem bisher habe ich das Gefühl dass
die Jungs echt was drauf haben können
[Musik]
das war's 7 Euro Haarschnitt in Panama
City hat super funktioniert mit
translator konnte ich hier sogar ein
bisschen mit dem quatschen auch wenn er
nicht besonders gesprächignen ist
Regenzeit in Panama deswegen suchen wir
uns jetzt irgendein stand bei dem
unterkommen und was essen können
also neben Ständen mit Früchten Säften
und so weiter natürlich auch
traditionelles Essen Reis chicken hier
wird unheimlich viel Fleisch gegessen
wo wir essen wollen
das denn
natürlich habe ich nichts von dem
verstanden was der Kollege mir da
erzählen wollte bis er wirklich die
Kamera bemerkt hat und auf nonverbale
Sprache gewechselt ist das habe ich dann
relativ schnell verstanden
es bis heute traditional phänomenian
food
nice wie viel das kostet weiß ich noch
nicht du bist dumm das nicht vorher zu
fragen als du das Beste was ich letzten
Tag auch schon immer gegessen habe so
übelst kranke Haut so wird einfach
überall zu gegessen in Panama wird auch
morgens Reis und Fleisch gegessen also
im Prinzip begleitet die Soße das
paramesische Essen durch den ganzen Tag
kann man geil es gibt nichts falsch zu
machen und kann man eigentlich an jeder
Ecke ziemlich gut essen
gehen
auch hier wieder 6 $ für die eine
Portion zwei Getränke und zwei Wasser
wahrscheinlich doppelt so viel wie wenn
wir einheimische gewesen wären aber
nichtsdestotrotz Portion so groß dass
zwei Leute davon komplett satt geworden
sind und jetzt immer noch was übrig ist
also da kann man wirklich nichts sagen
[Musik]
das hinter mir auch wieder Sinnbild für
Panama der Typ dort oben auf dem Dach
einfach in Schlappen keine richtige
Sicherung im Prinzip eine Schaukel und
der macht jetzt irgendwas an der Fassade
oder hängt neue Werbung auf also
wirklich völlig verrückt all das was
hier hinter mir seht ist jetzt wieder so
ein street food Kurt also keine Ahnung
10 bis 15 Restaurants auf der Vorder und
Hinterseite und das ist in den Bereichen
wo die Panama City Einwohner wirklich
wohnen absolut gang und gäbe das hier
überall und überall gibt's ziemlich
ähnliches essen aber ist auch überall
gut wir sind jetzt hier eine Markthalle
gegangen wahrscheinlich so einer der
Standorte an den man wirklich frisches
Zeug bekommt 500 Meter von dem Standort
entfernt wo wir gegessen haben
tatsächlich ist für in meinen Geschmack
die paramesische Küche etwas wenig
frisch im Markt habe ich dann mal
angefangen nach Preisen zu schauen und
zu recherchieren der kostet auf living
Index wird jedes Jahr mit New York City
quasi als Nullpunkt bestimmt und hilft
dabei Lebensunterhaltungskosten für
verschiedene Städte und Regionen
vergleichbar zu machen Panama City ist
laut diesem Index auf Platz 290 aller
auf 140 verglichenen Städte also
ziemlich weit unten und scheinbar
ziemlich günstig insgesamt sollten die
Lebensunterhaltungskosten 64,4%
günstiger sein als in New York ich
glaube aber das ist noch ein bisschen
mehr ist nach dem Essen ein Nachtisch
hinter mir seht ihr zwei klassische
Nachtische Straßenstände die jetzt
keinen direktes Mittagessen sind einmal
in Kokosnuss stand findet man so
ziemlich überall oder ein
klassenspanneresischer Eisstand im
Prinzip ein riesen Eisblock von dem
kleine raspeln abgemacht werden und dann
so eine Art Lush Eis rausgemacht wird
also mit Maracuja Topping mit
verschiedenen Geschmäckern kostet
ungefähr 1 $ schmeckt super nice und ist
perfekt bei so tropischen Klima
grundsätzlich ist es im Ausland wenig
ratsam Eis in irgendeiner Form zu essen
häufig wird bei Eiswürfeln oder auch so
einem Eisblock kein teures Flaschen
sondern günstiges Leitungswasser
verwendet das Leitungswasser ist
meistens nicht im Ansatz so gut
kontrolliert wie in Deutschland dazu
sind es unsere Mengen dann auch nicht
gewohnt und den Preis für solche Aktion
zahlt man als Mann dann meistens abends
auf der Toilette dieses Mal ging alles
gut
aber es hammer geil
Slush Eis super
ein oberride 5 Minuten oder 15
Gehminuten entfernt hurra Luxus absolute
luxusmalls so homol so ziemlich das
krasseste was geht und die Kulisse hat
sich auch etwas verändert
fünf Minuten in der Mall bisschen
rumgelaufen es wirkt absolut trostlos es
wirkt so als wäre das eine Mall eine
Idee für ein paar wenige in der Stadt
für die die in irgendwelchen Häusern
ganz oben sitzen aber als würde selbst
die das alles nicht interessieren also
es ist wirklich ein bisschen traurig mit
anzusehen die Mitarbeiter stehen draußen
vor ihren Läden und warten die Zeit ab
weil niemand drin ist ein Großteil der
Ladenflächen ist gar nicht vermietet
also jetzt nichts los und einfach
wirklich deutlich weniger Globus als man
sich die prunkvolle Seite der Stadt
hätte vorgestellt ist einfach traurig
irgendwie ich glaube wir haben mehr
davon wenn wir diesen trostlosen Ort
schnellstmöglich verlassen euch mal
lieber zeigen wie und wo wir schlafen
denn dieses Mal ist es ja tatsächlich in
den 100 € mit drin und dann noch auf die
Besonderheit und unsere Abendplanung
eingehen und das hier ist unser Zimmer
ist klein es einfach nur klein ist hat
wirklich gar nichts das hat ein Bett es
hat einen Schreibtisch und kein eigenes
Badezimmer wir sind in einem Hostel wir
haben uns für die günstigste
Einzelzimmer Variante entschieden wie
gesagt 31 € pro Person inklusive
Frühstück wir haben wenig Platz kein
Fenster nach draußen und Fenster zum
Gang Klimaanlage und im Prinzip war das
und zwei Nächte jetzt hier gelebt das
hat auch gut funktioniert es geht auch
noch günstiger das hier war jetzt aber
so das perfekte Mittelding für uns womit
wir gut klar gekommen sind eine weitere
nach ohne Fenster nach draußen nur mit
Klimaanlage und ohne eigenes Bad hätte
ich aber keinen Bock drauf
sechster Stock im Selina rooftop bar mit
Pool mit allem drum und dran was man
sich vorstellen kann wir haben gerade
Essen bestellt und so lassen wir dann
unseren Abend hier im Panama City
ausklingen und jetzt bin ich gespannt
was wir essen bekommen ziemlich
umfangreiche Karte Tacos Burritos alles
so in die Richtung preislich passt es
jetzt musst du noch geschmacklich
überzeugen und dann ist das ein
vernünftiger Abschluss für unsere Panama
City 100 €
das Zeug bekanntes Volk super
geil also wirklich drei Tacos absolute
zehn von zehn das allerbeste wäre wenn
ich mir jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr
bestellt hätte oh warte
ich habe mir mehr bestellt zehn von zehn
insgesamt ein wirklich gelungener Trip
nach Panama City und demselben Atemzug
starten wir ein neues komplett
subjektives Ranking der Städte die wir
mit 100 € bereisen herzlich willkommen
zum ersten wie sehr lohnt sich eine
Reise Ranking hierbei geht es nicht nur
um die Kosten sondern um die gesamte
experience zu bewerten sind Preis für
Anreise 100 € Budget Location von Faktor
Wohlfühlfaktor und ob ich noch mal hin
würde in jeder Kategorie sind insgesamt
bis zu 5 Punkten zu vergeben New York
City wird nachträglich von mir mit
insgesamt 23 von 30 Punkten bewertet
obwohl man wirklich aufs Geld achten
muss was insgesamt eine richtig geile
Erfahrung und ich würde sofort noch mal
hin bei Panama sieht es leider etwas
anders aus Preis Anreise zwei von fünf
Punkten 100 €, drei von fünf Punkten man
bezahlt eben in Dollern und man merkt
dass man irgendein Mix aus
südamerikanischen mittelamerikanischen
und amerikanischen Preisen bezahlt
Location drei von fünf es gibt Str es
gibt Inseln es gibt große Städte aber
nicht irgendwie nicht so aus den Socken
gehauen wie New York beispielsweise fun
factor drei von fünf es ist ziemlich
cool aber auch da hat es mich irgendwie
nicht so richtig abgeholt Wohlfühlfaktor
Digger es ist komplett subjektiv
irgendwie bin ich nicht so richtig warm
geworden mit dieser gesamten Location
mit den Leuten und es hat sich einfach
nicht so zu Hause angefühlt und der
letzte Punkt ein von fünf Punkten für
würde ich noch mal hin ich habe nämlich
keine Ambition noch mal hinzufahren 14
von 30 Punkten und damit auf Platz zwei
macht es gut bis zum nächsten Mal